being unsure and not knowing is actually
a great thing to show your students
right because it models that Curiosity
it models that question asking and you
can come back to them and say here's
what I learned and how I learned it
today on Chalk radio
how thinking like scientists can make us
better teachers
and how teachers can be powerful mentors
for future scientists
I'm Sarah Hansen for this episode I sat
down with Dr summer moral I started off
as a graduate student at MIT in biology
but I'm currently the instructor of ta
training in the biology Department
I actually spoke with Summer right
before she left MIT now she's a science
instructor at a secondary school in New
Hampshire
one of the reasons we were excited to
bring summer on the show was her unique
and Innovative approach to thinking
about teaching
I guess what I'm most interested in is
thinking about how we can apply all of
our research ways of thinking to the
classroom you know we all as scientists
get this training of asking questions
and iterating and looking at the
evidence and trying again based on that
evidence and I think that we can really
bring that into the classroom I'm a
first generation woman in science and
didn't have anyone in my family or
closed Circle who was a scientist I
didn't know what that looked like and so
for me having teachers who were Role
Models has been instrumental starting
from high school all the way through
college and graduate school so it seems
like
those life experiences sort of LED you
to be interested not only in biology
itself but the teaching of biology yeah
absolutely I think that you know they
gave me the passion for the subject
material but also were excellent models
of what a good teacher looks like can
you remember one person in particular
yeah my high school biology teacher Mr
janaki he was one of the first biology
teachers I ever had and he just
encouraged us to question and and not
just to sit there and accept what was in
the textbooks but actually think about
why is this the way that it is and how
does it work and I think that that
method of questioning really has left me
being curious about science and wanting
to impart that Curiosity to my students
in her role at MIT summer and her
colleagues were tasked with training
about 100 teacher assistants working in
the biology Department each year
some of these Tas were undergrads in a
teaching role for the very first time
I was curious what kinds of worries or
challenges new Tas usually came to her
with
I think the biggest one that we see is
worries about being wrong what do I do
when someone asks me a question and I
don't know the answer which I think is
something that every new teacher
struggles with and I love being able to
tell them that being unsure and not
knowing is actually a great thing to
show your students right because it
models that Curiosity it models that
question asking and you can come back to
them and say here's what I learned and
how I learned it
for summer teaching is a way to enhance
your scientific chops to approach
problems with humility and curiosity
but it's also an opportunity to help
students see science thinking in
practice
this encouragement for TAS to
intentionally model their science
thinking skills in the classroom is
Central to Summer's philosophy
I wanted to know what kinds of
experiences informed her approach to
teaching scientists how to teach biology
this is funny to say as someone who is
now a teaching professional but I in
high school and college was terrified of
public speaking like absolutely
terrified I could not get up on a stage
or in front of a room without like
shaking and and my voice would shake and
so for me by the time I got to graduate
school some of those nerves had gone
away I had done presentations for my
courses but I still felt that in my gut
the first time that I got up to teach us
am I gonna be able to
speak eloquently am I gonna be able to
be understood by this group of students
who are trying to learn something from
me and I think that that nervousness
that imposter syndrome was a really big
barrier and we had a great pre-semester
training run by one of the professors in
the department who tried to put us at
ease answer those questions about what
do you do when you don't know the answer
to a question but when I stepped into
the room it felt like all that went out
of my head and I just wasn't sure how it
was gonna go foreign
experiences as an instructor informed a
lot of her approach to teaching Tas she
also Drew upon insights from other
students and instructors to make sure
the approaches that Tas implemented were
inclusive and equitable
what often folks don't realize is how
different folks experiences coming into
college right people are coming from all
different places all different types of
school systems and that means that they
aren't starting on equal footing and so
if we treat all our students equally
that ignores who they are as people
so in her ta instruction summer teaches
a strategy for creating a more inclusive
classroom
this strategy is called multiple hands
multiple voices we really focus on
participation strategies and how we ask
our students to show up and participate
in the room and we try to talk about
strategies that are more inclusive and
allow for people to have space to think
and to respond in different ways and so
multiple hands multiple voices is one of
these techniques where normally if you
ask a question and you call on the first
person who raises their hand it's often
the same student every time or the same
select few and those are the people that
think fast on their feet but if you wait
until multiple hands are raised and you
call on multiple different people to
share their perspectives it gives more
time to think and also provides a
picture of maybe how different people
think differently about a particular
problem I often ask folks to kind of
either count to six in their head really
slowly or like sing a verse of happy
birthday like whatever you gotta do to
fill that space in your own head because
it can be really daunting to just look
out and see blank faces but one of the
things we talk about with inclusive
participation strategies is transparency
and letting folks know that you are
giving them conscious time to think and
so sometimes it means saying I'm gonna
give you 30 seconds to think about this
question while I erase the board and
just leaving that space to know that
they have time to think can be really
powerful and less awkward for the DA's
this focus on encouraging students to
draw on their different experiences to
create space for different ways of
thinking and learning is powerful and it
doesn't start and end with classroom
instruction
as summer explains grading is another
important piece of creating Equity as an
instructor
there's a whole session in her ta
training focused solely on this kind of
approach
what we really try to do throughout all
of this series is provide tools and
takeaways that Tas can bring into their
classrooms so we try to offer this
session right as Cas have their first
assignment they need to grade
and it feels real feels concrete and
they're left asking this question of how
do I grade effectively and more
importantly how do I grade equitably for
the students in my classroom and what
that means is thinking about are you
being objective with your grading and
are you allowing any implicit bias to
enter into your great gang and that's a
hard question to answer because of
course it's implicit it's unconscious
and so creating structures for yourself
as a teacher as a teaching assistant so
that you can combat and mitigate those
issues of equitability is really
important and so we work with Tas to
design and Implement rubrics for grading
we encourage them to do anonymized
grading as much as possible and we
introduce them to programs that allow
them to do that as well as give detailed
feedback
it struck me as I was talking with
Summer that her teaching doesn't only
emphasize modeling science thinking as
an instructor it also emphasizes
modeling empathy and care for students
as human beings
one session of the TA course is titled
supporting our students and for me this
was where the focus on humanity and
empathy really came through
grounding these issues of student
support in real life scenarios is so
important for not only Tas that are
experiencing some of those challenges
but also have not yet experienced them
right they can start to think about how
they would respond so this whole session
is thinking about how we can listen to
our students well how we can actively
listen to them and respond to them in a
way that helps them to grow and empowers
them to make their own decisions and so
not only is it thinking about challenges
that our students face maybe the first
exam that they've ever just totally
bombed or something that might be going
on in their personal life that's
affecting their learning but it can also
be these challenging scenarios where
where students are challenging us to be
better teachers and so I often tell them
as because I give them the list of
scenarios to choose for from as we're
going through this and I I asked them to
choose something that either feels very
relevant to them or most challenging to
them and I think that that's really
important that they can push themselves
in that way and so the scenario the
student that calls you in this was
actually an example that I took directly
from my own classroom so I was teaching
a cell bio course as a teaching
assistant
and we were talking about genetics and
often in genetics related topics and
genetics courses we throw out mom and
dad as being the genetic donors and Mom
and Dad maternal paternal very gendered
terms and I had a student who raised
their hand this was a non-binary student
and they let me know that this kind of
felt weird to them that we were using
all of these gendered terms to talk
about a very scientific thing genetic
donors and they felt that it was
exclusive of their experience and I
really for me in that moment wished that
I had thought about this ahead of time
because all I could do was thank that
student for letting me know and say you
know I'm gonna look up more about how we
can be more inclusive in genetic
language there is research and papers
out there that put forth new systems of
explaining genetic terminology but if I
had thought about it ahead of time I
would have been able to really expand on
that and talk about the intersections
between the way we talk about things as
scientists and kind of societal issues
and and societal Reflections on what
we're learning
given how complex it can be to implement
these concepts of inclusivity equity and
empathy let alone as a first-time ta I
was curious how summer implemented
systems to provide feedback especially
since so much of these DA's work was
being done in real life real-time
classrooms
this was one of our key priorities that
we identified as something that Tas were
looking for they wanted to know if they
were just shouting to the void or if
what they were doing was actually making
a difference and having an impact and so
one of The Graduate students that I
worked with during the needs assessment
process he developed a worksheet for an
observer to go through to kind of think
about community and engagement and how
those were playing out in the classroom
for anyone who wants to be observed I
have folks sign up we usually get about
20 25 teaching observations per semester
and I have them choose a time that
they'd like to be observed and sit at
the back of their classroom try not to
intrude and just listen and I type up
notes and those are notes for them to
keep but importantly those are notes for
them to learn and they are are not
evaluative in any way so I try to create
a space where Tas feel like it is a
learning experience and not something
that they're going to be judged for
right getting observed is a terrifying
experience even if it's someone that
they know and are comfortable with we
meet together afterwards to look at
those notes we talk about what's going
really well we talk about the ways
they're connecting with their students
and then we brainstorm and discuss ideas
that might make things go more smoothly
or might engage those students that tend
to be quieter in the back of their class
so it really is just a an opportunity
for us to touch base and for the Tas to
learn it's so interesting I think
culturally we almost think of teaching
as sort of an innate ability versus
something a skill set that can be
cultivated and practiced and I feel like
programs like this really emphasize that
growth model and that you know I think
that's why people are afraid to be
observed because they're like oh I'm not
good enough instead of you know I
haven't developed those skills yet but
you know here's a a program that can
help me do that just like if you were
learning to play the flutes of course
you're going to be terrible the first
few times
until you have some modeling and some
learning and then you get better
absolutely I think you know as their
students are learning they are learning
too and the next time that they go to
teach it'll be a different group of
students it might be a different course
but they'll have taken all of what they
learned about teaching and connecting
with students into that next experience
and even Beyond teaching folks can think
about how it applies to their roles as
mentors in the lab as scientific
communicators and presenters
now if you're an instructor of another
subject you might be wondering whether
Summer's tools for biology pedagogy
would work for you so I asked summer
whether her ocw materials would be
adaptable for other subjects and
instructors
yeah absolutely I think what I've tried
to do in the materials I've developed is
leave space to make it adaptable to your
particular discipline so often for
example when we look at providing
feedback and looking at grading
practices what I do is I pull a problem
or a question from one of the courses
that the Tas are in and so right now in
the materials it'll say something like
pull something from your ta's courses
and it could be an essay question that's
graded it could be more of a
problem-based question but absolutely I
think with some reflection on what the
needs are you'll absolutely be able to
adapt these materials one of the big
things not only did we reach out to
stakeholders in developing this program
but try to match the pacing of our
sessions with what our Tas were
experiencing during the semester and so
that would be the advice I would give is
try to tailor it to the ta's direct
experience as much as possible
before I left my conversation with
summer I asked her if she was excited to
move on to her next position teaching
students at the secondary level
I am I'm super excited to transition to
the high school world as I mentioned
that was where I first learned to love
biology and so I'm super excited to get
to be a mentor and a role model for
those high school students that don't
yet know that science is their thing and
we'll get to do lots of cool biology
together
if you are feeling motivated to improve
instruction in your field and want to
teach with Summer morals materials
you'll soon find them all on our MIT
opencourseware website as always they
are open and free
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from Cambridge
Massachusetts I'm your host Sarah Hansen
from MIT opencourseware MIT chalk radios
producers include myself Brett patchy
and Dave leshansky the show notes for
this episode were written by Peter
Chipman be sure to give us a follow on
Instagram Twitter and wherever you get
your podcasts